hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to a
video edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my readers Paul who's asking about how
to make money selling advertising on his
website bubble emailed me this morning
he's got a business in Zambia it's a
magazine cater towards entrepreneurs and
he's having a hard time generating
revenue there since the business climate
isn't that great in Zambia and you
wanted my advice so Pablo here's three
tips that I hope will help you grow your
business we're gonna get started by
clicking on Pablo's websites so you
included it here in the email and as it
loads up it looks like a decent website
the first thing I noticed though is that
it says January 2010 edition so the
website is over a year old and that's
not a great sign for anybody who's
coming to the site as a visitor or as an
advertiser lower down here looks like
it's talking about hosting the World Cup
well obviously the World Cup is over now
so if I'm a reader if I'm an advertiser
coming to this website I'm probably not
gonna stick around very long so if
you're trying to attract advertisers you
want to show that you always have
up-to-date content that's gonna be of
interest for them if I'm an advertiser
I'm probably not gonna invest budget in
this website right now if you're running
an offline magazine in an online site
maybe the offline magazine is really
expensive to produce and you might not
have the advertisers to support it yet
so start online it's it's a lot cheaper
a hosting class herb not that much so
it's an easy way to keep your website up
to date and showcase that you have new
content and try to sell advertising
online and maybe generate a revenue base
that you can then move it offline as
well to your actual you know physical
magazines but you want to make sure that
you always have an up-to-date website
that is showing new content that's going
to be attractive for any reader if it's
a visitor to your site or an advertiser
to want to stick around and get more
involved with your company the next
thing I want to talk about is how do you
actually make advertising revenue from
this website and there may not be much
of a business climate in Zambia right
now but there are pretty good ways to
find out the type of content you can use
that might attract some advertisers a
great tool that I like to use is
the Google Keyword tool and what this
will do is allow you to type in any
keyword and it will tell you the
different advertising routes for it so I
can start off by doing international
locations and let's just type in Zambia
the magazine and website deal with
Zambia and different business
opportunities in Zambia so we'll do a
quick search see what type of things pop
up and what you can do here with this
tool is on the right-hand side where it
says columns you can go and pick
approximate cost per click and this is
the estimated revenue that you can
expect to make every time somebody
clicks on one of your ads so you want to
try to target content you can then sort
it by cost per click you want to try to
target content that pays better so if
you look at it and anything related to
insurance investment center or travel
insurance neighbors inter market bank so
these are all keywords that are paying
more if we try to change our location
let's for example go down to Zambia we
could do a search and this is all
English language and scroll down and you
can see it changed a little bit so MSE
Zambia Indo Zambia bank access Bank
Zambia invest in Zambia so things look
at the bank so if I was writing content
and try to figure out how I can sell
advertising I would try to target things
with live into the banking industry
because that seems to be paying pretty
well now these could still be pretty low
click so that the best click here you're
looking at you know just over four and a
half dollars what you might want to
consider doing is trying to target an
American audience because they tend to
have the highest pay per click so if we
go to United States instead of Zambia
see what kind of results we get here so
before we saw a four and a half dollars
here we're looking at twenty five
dollars almost so it was a big
difference in the cost per click because
it's more advertising revenue targeting
an American audience so if you look at
mining companies investments in Zambia
insurance in Zambia it still is targeted
to a business audience which could work
for the magazine but a great way to be
able to get started and started in
you might be to try to target a more
American audience because you can easily
sell advertising to them and start
making money with your business so
something to think about I don't want to
push you into something that you're not
comfortable with but definitely uses
tool to figure out the types of content
that you can write where advertisers are
interested in and then that can help
guide your your policy moving forward
start hopefully getting YouTube making
some money and then able to grow your
business and eventually move to your
offline magazine as well the last tip I
want to give here is to try to think
about your content strategy and try to
not write everything yourself I've
talked about this in the past if you
look at my website as an example I
started off by writing a whole bunch of
content and it was good content we got a
lot of visitors from it but there's
always gonna be limited by how much I
can write my time is limited so I'm
always going to be limited on my growth
so what I decided to do was I ended up
hiring somebody to write these famous
entrepreneur profiles and she does a
really good job and she's working for a
number of years now and then I reached
out and started attracting other
successful entrepreneurs to give their
advice so we've partnered up with some
pretty big-name people in the world of
entrepreneurship and they contribute
content and then we also have other
people who are business coaches
marketing consultants sales consultants
as an example and they write articles
for our website too so if I click on the
business coach section for example it'll
load up a whole list of different
business coach articles that are written
by business coaches on our website and
if I scroll down you'll see here that
there's a whole bunch of people who are
all business coaches who are writing for
the website and goes down down down down
down
and so they've contributed a whole a
whole bunch of content to my site and
it's great for them because they get a
lot of exposure it's great for me
because we have lots of good new content
to the website without me having to
write it and it's great for my readers
because there's a lot more useful
content for them to learn how to grow
their business so I definitely start to
look at how you can attract other people
to start writing for you so it's not
just you writing everything yourself and
if you start it online instead of
offline with the magazine then it's a
lot cheaper to get up and going you can
start selling advertising and earn
enough money to then grow your business
and
to other ventures and other
opportunities so that's it for this
video remember keep producing new
content follow the money and get some
help to get people writing for your
website I hope you enjoyed the video
please give it a thumbs up below if you
did and it also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment stay tuned to the next
episode
you